[Music]
welcome back from the fox Studio Lot in
Los Angeles we're happy to be here for
more than a hundred years the United
States has as a matter of official
policy oppose dictatorships around the
world
but what if tyranny arrived right next
door what would that look like and what
would our government do in response
would we Liberate the people living
under authoritarian rules we have around
the world
that is a topic of our upcoming Tucker
Carlson Originals documentary O Canada
here's a first look at what we found
The Cost of Freedom is always high
but Americans have always paid it some
nations may be able to turn a blind eye
to atrocities in other countries
the United States of America is
different fortunately for the oppressed
America's influence is considerable
[Music]
oh man
we like to say people kind exactly all
right
police then then moved in and arrested
me
in the entire time that I was in prison
oh shut me Point Blank
I've got a bruised like my hands were
bleeding please show me the rest right
now I was arrested and cuffed and put in
jail
greatest danger of all would be to do
nothing we care about saving innocent
lives the Tyrant will soon be gone
the day of your Liberation is near
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight